[Musique]
à l'heure du déjeuner au siège de la
banque populaire
comment cultiver sur un compost fabriqué
à partir de déchets alimentaires
et d'octroyer avec dvd
[Musique]
le travail qui est intéressant chez ford
et revenir c'est qu'ils regardent
précisément quelles sont les conditions
techniques économiques environnementales
qui permettent à ce genre de ferme qui
préfigure l'avenir de se développer
c'est un business qui est d'utilité
solidaire c'est pas le business pur
c'est le business n'a d'intérêt général
parce que ça correspond aux nouveaux
besoins de la société n'ont de sens que
si on prend le plus aux critères
économiques oui c'est pas une
rentabilité à trois chiffres comme
certaines activités
si on prend
environnementaux et sociaux on est
nettement plus performant que le large
majorité d'entreprises ont dit
aujourd'hui très rentable
[Musique]
maintenant c'est plus un intérêt amusé
ça m'intéresse aux courses et alors
c'est pas votre truc finalement donc
c'est des gens curieux pouvoir tout
simplement alors après on essaye de
présenter des solutions qui peuvent à
une microchaîne s'adapter à des
problématiques urbaines
mais nous aussi c'est comme ça qu'on
avance en travaillant là dessus
loin des place financière parisienne la
première ferme d'avenir est né ici en
touraine
il y a quatre ans à l'origine du projet
maxime de rostolan un jeune ingénieur en
environnement au profil plus digital que
manuel 40% des gens qui veulent
s'installer aujourd'hui sont des néo
ruraux sont des gens qui n'ont pas cet
héritage paysans et je pense que il faut
réconcilier la ville et la campagne et
faire en sorte que tous ceux qui ont
envie de ce sens dans leur travail au
quotidien tous ceux qui ont envie de
pouvoir manger convenablement à des prix
raisonnables tout en rémunérant ya les
lecteurs mais il faut les associer à
cette dynamique le maître du potager
c'est xavier mathias formateur et apôtre
de la permaculture converti au concept
ferme d'avir ce petit truc là là qui est
ridicule pour l'instant alors il est
ridicule maintenant il est tout petit
laid à moitié à moitié c'est comme ça
c'était que très cultivé jusqu'à la fin
du xviie à peu près là disparu ensuite
ce truc là c'est bon à tomber par terre
alors effectivement on va pas sauver le
monde avec ça on va pas révolutionner
les déséquilibres alimentaires mondiaux
par contre voilà vous voulez vous faire
plaisir vous avez la chance d'avoir un
jardin alors cultivée du sheikh vie que
c'est vraiment vraiment délicieux alors
plantes vivaces rustique pas de
ravageurs pas de maladie vous allez
pouvoir le multipliez vous même d'un
l'année suivante on en fait 10 il a tout
pour plaire et surtout il a un autre
truc pour plaire c'est qu'il est
vraiment très très bon
c'est à l'ombre du château de la
bourdaisière que prospère ce modèle de
micro ferme sur un hectare et demi de
terres cultivées selon des méthodes
inspirées de la permaculture le pari
semblait fou prouver qu'on peut payer
trois salariés avec une production
maraîchère biologique en recréant un
écosystème rien impossible selon hélène
le téno éminente spécialiste de la
transition écologique en gros
aujourd'hui ce qu'on sait c'est que si
on développait tout un réseau de fermes
agro écologiques comme la sphère de la
bourdaisière en france on ferait 3
milliard d'euros d'économies par an en
france notamment sur les dépenses de
santé par une alimentation plus saine
sans pesticides plus équilibrée et puis
également avec des retombées économiques
locales plus d'emplois plus de recettes
fiscales locales et un meilleur partage
voilà d'une nouvelle richesse pour tous
pendant cette phase d'expérimentation la
micro ferme accueille des stagiaires
venus de tous horizons pour participer à
l'aventuré de semaine ok du coup les
garçons vous pouvez aller chercher les
gorilles est dans l'atelier et quand tu
lui montres ou là vous avez continué car
vous avez vous devez terminer vendredi
qu'elle est là et j'ai toujours vécu
dans la ville très dans un bureau je
trouve ça un peu à carcassonne du néo
rivaux vidéo virale qui veut se
rapprocher un peu plus de la tête mais
c'est ça trouver un sens et puis faire
du ca faire du concret quoi comment
quand on travaille là le la terre qu'on
plante pour les
qu'on voit le résultat de son travail
c'était du concret
[Musique]
les fruits et légumes sont livrés dans
les magasins bio de la région comme bio
line est une scop à montlouis sur loire
ça fait défaut bouquet on peut se faire
soit nouvelle salade soit soit nouvelle
petit côté de légumes 1 cuil je trouve
ça un petit peu puis s'en vont un petit
peu plus tard c'est vrai que c'est le
retard de ces forts en par contre à la
mi-temps tout seul
les maraîchers bio cassis qui vont se
baser sur des techniques un peu plus
anciennes ils ont pas les n'ont pas les
reins assez solides entre guillemets
pour pour s'essayer à des nouveaux
nouvelles techniques culturales on
s'arrête là la permaculture que 1000 mhz
est en passe je pense qu un maraîcher
classique n'aura pas ne pourra pas le
faire ne pourra pas essayer de le mettre
en place ce sera trop dangereux pour lui
il ya trop de danger financier en fait
il
à quelques centaines de kilomètres près
de rouen la ferme marre des rufo a
rejoint le réseau fermes d'avenir comme
une quarantaine d'autres structures à
travers la france après avoir passé six
mois la bourdaisière comme volontaire
marque apporte son expérience ici en
normandie
voilà l'idée c'est ça oui ça non c'est
par contre sans remuer de côté et après
tu vas là sûrement on trouvait battut
recoller mais la patronne c'est linda
aujourd'hui elle présente son domaine
lapierre diplômé d'une école de commerce
comme elle et qui est en charge de la
communication des fermes d'avenir les
partis de zéro tout ce que tu vois là ça
a été planté par nous remonter par nous
laissèrent on a plus d'une centaine de
familles qui concerne le légume
régulièrement donc on a aussi le
challenge de d'arriver à les satisfaire
on a 100 espèces végétales qui ont elles
mêmes au minimum au minimum dix variétés
donc on se retrouve avec plus de 1000
produits différents ok
alimentaires bio entre les légumes les
fruits les aromatiques un petit peu les
yeux on que la transfo c'est les
confitures aux que la fourche à la
fourchette le combat du réseau fermes
d'avenir c'est de changer les règles du
jeu pour tenir compte de ce qu'on
appelle les bénéfices cacher qu'on
regarde le prix d'une tomate
conventionnel que l'on appelle chimiques
et le prix d'une tomate bio issus d'un
système agro écologiques en fait oui la
tomate issues du système agro
écologiques et coûte 2 euros 50
mais la tomate qui coûte 2 euros en fait
écoute pas 2 euros parce que si on prend
en compte le coût de la dépollution des
eaux le coût de la pollution et de
l'impact que ça pour la santé etc qu'on
paye tous collectivement dans nos impôts
cette tomate et coûte beaucoup plus cher
à la société
et en plus nous nos tomates à 2,50 au
delà de sa valeur économique et de
l'emploi décret elle a un impact social
environnemental beaucoup plus forte pour
démontrer qu'une micro ferme et plus
productifs qu'une exploitation
traditionnelle
un comité d'une douzaine d'experts a été
constitué avec des sociologues des
médecins et des économistes
leur mission convaincre les politiques
est ce que ces fermes
elles sont plus riches que ce qu'on veut
bien dire oui alors elles sont plus
riches d'au moins 50% que ce que la
comptabilité voudrait bien nous tire et
en plus elle rend des services à nos
sociétés qui ont une valeur de plus de
3000 euros par hectare cultivé donc des
services de purification de l'eau de
préservation du climat de santé et donc
ça une valeur énorme pour la société
qu'on a été capable de chiffrer et ses
arguments là qu'on veut faire valoir
maintenant on est quand même à
contre-courant total de l'agriculture
aujourd'hui et même quand on est bio
parmi les bio ou encore une catégorie un
peu spécial on n'est pas toujours
contrer on parle de rêveurs d'utopistes
et donc c'est vrai que c'est très
important aujourd'hui de conforter un
peu nos modèles par des preuves un peu
de recherche etc pourra vraiment prouver
aux yeux des autres et de se fédérer
pour moi là c'est l'heure maintenant de
se mettre en réseau et de croire à la
force du réseau pour porter plus haut
nos projets
pour l'avoir jouée à la ferme du mont
jamais imagine couac est d'ailleurs une
fois qu'une fois tous les trois jours et
l'équipe de la micro ferme
marre des rues faut continuer à se
battre pour faire évoluer la
réglementation qui défavorise les micros
exploitation au profit des géants de la
monoculture
[Musique]
retour à la bourdaisière en touraine une
fois tous les deux mois n'a ferme
d'avenir ouvre ses portes aux visiteurs
l'humain qui est au coeur de la
réflexion qu'on mène ici de calais la
place de celui qui cultive
quelle est la place de ceux qui vont
acheter de ses produits etc
c'est ça qui nous intéresse c'est
comment on peut trouver une espèce
d'harmonie un petit peu là dedans l'idée
étant que chacun on a tous besoin les
uns des autres
nous ce qu'on essaie de promouvoir une
agriculture qui soit relié à son passé
qui soit ben ça veut pas dire qu'on est
passéiste ou quoi que ce soit et et que
c'était mieux avant avec l'année j'étais
plus blanches et compagnie n'ont baissé
que par contre on peut pas totalement ce
coupé comme ça de son passé de son
histoire qui est une évolution sur les
matériaux etc
même sur le même sur l'ergonomie sur le
voilà là c'est vrai que la roue gonflé
comme ça c'est quand même vachement
mieux que la roue ferraille etc donc
mais toujours un lien quoi est là notre
agriculture est complètement en fait
complètement coupée de son passé c'est
une autre culture
mais je ne vous cache pas que j'y
croyais pas jusqu'à maintenant je ramène
un peu d'engrais je me dis fumier je
retourne la terre aux mots novembre bref
à l'ancienne quoi et puis maintenant on
nous dit non faut pas trop toucher aux
commandes la partie souterraine de la
surface de la terre
chacun fait ce qu'il veut en fait de
tout ça je pas sur moi d'avoir raison
donc je vais pas chercher à convaincre
alors que moi même je suis pas du tout
sûr du résultat est ce qu'il faut faire
comme ça est ce que c'est une bonne idée
pas une mauvaise idée
ce que je sais par contre c'est que et
ça c'est important c'est qu'on le sait
en conscience par contre c'est à dire
qu'on le fait proprement en respectant
les humains qui travaillent avec nous en
respectant le sol en respectant l'eau en
évitant de salir ou quoi que ce soit ou
de l'abîmé on le fait sans vénalité dire
sans volonté d'enrichissement donc à ce
moment là là effectivement moi je me
sens libre par rapport à ça le faire ici
le meilleur filtre c'est la terre dont
20 ans j'espère que y'aura plus à
marquer ab sur les produits de bonne
qualité mais qu'on mettra plutôt warning
sur les sur les produits qui ont des
produits chimiques potentiellement
dangereux
j'aimerais aussi que d'ici 20 ans on
puisse rémunérer les agriculteurs pour
l'ensemble des services qu'ils rendent
ils traitent la qualité de l'eau il
préserve la santé des gens il capte du
carbone crée de l'emploi et dynamiser
les territoires et ça si on intègre pas
ça dans leur bilan comptable on voit que
c'est compliqué parce que le panier
moyen des ménages pour l'alimentation a
largement diminué ces dernières
décennies
et donc c'est quelque part une volonté
politique une manoeuvre politique de que
d'encourager ce système
dans dix ans la moitié des agriculteurs
seront partis à la retraite est remplacé
en partie par deux jeunes néo ruraux qui
n'ont pas grandi à la campagne ce sont
eux qui portent désormais l'espoir d'un
véritable changement